good morning everybody today we're gonna
paint a portrait pick a partner that's
so good can i see yours
that is great
never shown my feelings in public how do
you know when you have a crash i have a
theory first insta story is the person
you're thirstiest for
mine is called
call zuwabi
i have a huge crush what's her name
kelso
i don't know what this is but i like
it to pull your hair out scream it out
the window for the whole world to hear
kind of deal
[Music]
wow no i'm i'm stupid
i hate when people say i'm brave you're
transitioning so young i don't tell you
how brave you are it's not that brave if
you're just being who you are
these are
for you
carl and likes you yeah well i like like
you if you don't like me just tell me i
still want to be your friend i didn't
say that we could live our own life or
spend the rest of our life wondering
what if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's only dating you for the woke points
what did you call her
you are my exceptional daughter and what
is unique about you does not make you
hard to love
for the first time in my life i'm
actually excited about what's to come i
truly feel anything's possible
[Music]
oh my god
go away that is so awkward
[Music]
[Music]
you